[Musique]
pour le taux d'incidence au niveau
régional on est aujourd'hui à 290 cas
pour 100000 habitants avec un taux de
positivité à 7% et pour les yvelines
on est à un taux d'incidence à 236 cas
pour 100000 habitants et un taux de
positivité à 6,9 pour cent et pour les
taux d'occupation des lits de soins
critiques en réa par les patients qu'aux
vide en ile de france on est à 125 8 9%
et dans les yvelines on est à 109 4%
donc en fait ça veut dire que au niveau
épidémiologique la situation continue à
s'améliorer on a bien une baisse de ces
indicateurs depuis plusieurs semaines
même si on reste quand même sur des des
chiffres encore assez haut et là on note
depuis trois jours une petite
stabilisation de ces chiffres ça ne
descend plus et ça reste sur ce plateau
un petit peu élevé en ile-de-france on à
85% des pcr qui sont criblés donc c'est
le la petite manipulation pour les et
laboratoires pour pouvoir avoir un
séquençage sur ces variants et
aujourd'hui on est à 67 5% de variants
britannique
donc là on est sur une stabilisation et
on est à onze pour cent ne va rien
brésilien ou sud-africain
et pour le coup là ça monte depuis
plusieurs semaines
depuis la fin du mois d'avril et toutes
les semaines de mai en moyenne au niveau
régional on va ressentons va recevoir à
peu près 600 mille doses donc de façon
hebdomadaire pour pouvoir vacciner la
population pour les y viennent on a
toujours nos 17 centres de vaccination
ils sont ouverts tout ce week-end de
l'ascension puisque vous savez qu'il ya
l'opération tous sur le pot donc tout le
monde joue le jeu a ouvert des créneaux
spécifiques on a également ouvert deux
centres de vaccination éphémère ces
quatre jours la du week-end de
l'ascension à magnanville et avec guet
lundi 17 mai on ouvre un nouveau centre
pérenne à bonnières-sur-seine donc pour
l'intercommunalité des portes d'île de
france
hélas elle enterre coupe qui n'avait pas
encore son centre le 25 mai on va
également ouvrir un nouveau centre
au chesnay et en quelques chiffres à
mercredi parce que là j'ai pas encore
les chiffres stabiliser on était à plus
de 485 milles vaccination dans les
yvelines tout cumulé injection 1 et 2
plus de 341 milles vaccination en primo
et plus de cent quarante et une seconde
injection